question says this is the exact wedding
actually a geometric series has it even
number of terms the sum of the whole
series is five times the sum of the
terms in the odd places reset again GPA
from even number terms the sum of the
whole series is five times bigger that
was some of if you just take the odd
terms the terms in the odd places and I
think they also tell you that the common
ratio is not equal to one okay which is
important in a minute
find the common ratio that's the
question okay now okay what I like about
this question is that if you as you see
when we unpack the answer it takes all
of the normal things that you know about
geometric series in fact this is
markedly easier than some of the
application series and sequence
questions though it's like just a
tangled mess of lots and lots of lines
there's a very small number of lines for
this but there's logic that you need to
apply to it that most people because
some non-routine more editing of the
question
they don't even know where to begin okay
so here's where I'm going to start is a
GP it has an even number of terms every
GP is in this form right what will my
last taking my last term the nth term
would be a R to the N minus 1 okay now
for reasons they'll become clear in a
second and you'll probably be asking
like how did I go to write this and the
answer is I didn't find worked out after
the next couple lines and I need it I'm
going to put the second last term in as
well which is one MLS and then he comes
the last one does that make sense so
there's my whole series this could be
any GP right I don't know anything
special about this yet that's the sum of
the whole series I'm going to call this
some new from all terms now I want the
terms in the odd places that's the first
third fifth seventh etc all those places
so I'm gonna call that this sum on the
odd smells okay now you can see and this
is why I've written a few extra terms I
can pull out those odd terms quite
easily
right so for example he's the first one
that's pretty easy what's the next term
I'm interested in this series and
squared okay now my next one would be a
r2 the form that I leave that one what's
going to happen here which of these
terms is the one that I want okay
because one of them has to be on which
one now here's the thing if I look back
to the question the whole GP this thing
has an even number of terms so whatever
that is it's an even term right it might
be the 20th term or the 40th all about
100 but it's gonna be even that means
this one has to be one does that make
sense so the last term will be this guy
okay plus I should I should actually put
me off for here so I have a whole
pattern so this is what I got okay this
is the sum of the odd terms okay and
here's what's really about this right
the question simply tells me that this
is five times bigger than this so it
ought to unpack this I'm just going to
say well hold on the first term is any
GP any GP at all and I know what the sum
of a GP is it is a times what now I can
I can say this forwards or backwards it
doesn't really matter right but if I've
got that on the new Branigan on that
denominator I have okay that's equal to
five times okay he comes to thinking it
right with a second piece of thinking
the first piece of thinking was went
recognizing that's the last term
the second piece of thinking is what are
all the pieces in this series well and
easily enough for me the first time is
still a ok then here I need to think
about the rich here I'll have a look
yeah you can see every time I'm going
back an r-square because I'm skipping
terms does that make sense right so in
here instead of are like offs we're in a
pause for a second if you see this
immediately don't shine it out but the
rest of us think it through how many
turns will be in the series stop and
think about it for a second
okay have a look at the way I've written
it look at the way I've written it right
can you see can you see that when I
formed this series right every time I
was missing a turn you see it sir
miss your turn do you see that because
there's an even number of terms every
odd term is matched up with an even turn
right if there was an odd number of
terms then I wouldn't know that if there
was like one two three four five right
when I get these odd ones out they don't
all match up do you see that but if
there is an even number of terms every
odd term matches up with an even one do
you agree with that so that means
because there's an even number term
there must be exactly half the number of
terms as they were in my first okay so
if they were in terms last time it's
gonna be and on to how many terms are in
this series and so there are n terms
right don't forget excuse me there's an
honor zero there right so if I count
from here one two three four five six
seven n minus one but I forgot that one
so that's the in turn right so there are
n terms here there are n on two terms
here this part is still the same okay
and then on the denominator minus one
okay that was all the hot pot the rest
of its just some algebra okay watch
watch is it delightfully at fault I'm
gonna leave this I'm gonna leave this
the same because it'll all sort of
collapse in a second on the right hand
side I've got five a what happens to
this guy that's RT n minus 1 because
look at the indices they just multiplied
together so this is R to the n minus 1
this denominator I could leave it like
that but there's a nicer way I can write
either way
extended yeah I'm going to take
difference of squares right now you have
a look at this okay have a look at all
this terms on the left-hand side every
term on the left-hand side is also on
the right-hand side right so I can
cancel a I can cancel on n minus one and
I can cancel ah - what because because
why can I cancel it because I was not
equal to one they told me that right at
the beginning I wasn't just raven so
that i could do that much so now what's
left on the left-hand side I have one on
the right hand side I have and one
afters ah yeah
so a plus one is five so hours for now
I'm just going through all this algebra
it's a weed way to phrase the question
so I'm not all that confident at the
moment that I've nailed it so you know
what I'm just gonna test it out it's not
that hard I don't need to know if the
first term is I don't need to know how
many terms there are that's interesting
this is completely in the universe all
you need is the common ratio so I'm just
gonna pick a first term I'm just gonna
pick a number of terms just to see if
this will work right nice easy first
term how about one right if my common
ratio is all that I'm going to get
something like that that'll do that's it
even under test right okay what's this
equal to this is 80 and that's five yeah
okay let's pick out the odd terms now
yeah yeah that's 17th which is 85 times
just like I was supposed to get right in
fact if you think about it your
intuition should tell you of course this
should work right because what happens
when you add the next pair of terms me
add the next pair of terms the next one
will be 256 and 1024 do you agree with
that now when you think about this
series down here how it's growing its
going to get that right whatever the
next term is it's going to be four times
bigger right so when you think of a big
series you're getting five of them right
so every time you add a pair of terms
you're adding this to the little series
and you're adding five of them to the
series which is why this is the case
okay
nope because I can change it
I can change it let's make this series 2
plus 8 plus 8 plus 128 the same thing
kind of just got noticed right you will
have exactly the same because of this
guy they even do it with fractions if I
wanted to but I don't serve the ego I've
contented myself that I remember